here we go oh my god that's great that's
gonna make your video we're doing okay
making sure there's nothing else in our
way we can't give edge coaster noise
have all failed to get out zoom out I
think it's gonna cross the road
oh my gosh were so close yeah we are
we're gonna stop just pass this pose how
much they keep shooting
gotcha hey right now we've got it Lance
powder I got the data just to our East
it's about five miles east of pretty
prairie getting ready to cross the road
oh my god I'm Jim uh I'm calling it out
okay but um what kind of like in a bad
spot Wow look at home no matter what oh
it's changing direction rolling people
aren't keep rolling we have we'll just
rely on I am
you can hear it you can hear it is too
great oh god that funnels is beautiful